dans salut les terriens qui a très bien
marché et 1,1 million de téléspectateurs
on a pu découvrir etienne qui a une
grande particularité il est en couple
avec une poupée qui s'appelle rna oui
regarde king un homme équilibré bien
dans ses pompes
mais votre vie amoureuse prend un tour
particulier le 3 août 2015 puisque vous
rencontrer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut absolument vous sortir de
l'esprit l'image de la poupée gonflable
pour vieux pervers des années 80 on en
est à des années lumière de façon quand
on achète une poupée comme ça c'est pas
pour le sexe et vous dites je
n'oublierai jamais son regard assez son
regard qui m'a provoqué vraiment un coup
de foudre
même si beaucoup de gens ne voir en elle
ou en ces poupées avec un objet moi j'ai
ressenti vraiment des émotions
alors alors alors ça mais couvert un peu
pauvre homme il fait plus de peine coach
cet homme sort en public en famille que
sa poupée ok stop faut vraiment consulté
là ça urge vite un psy il ya eu plein de
réactions et la poupée lui a coûté 3000
euros alors que trois mille euros c'est
le prix de base et après la customiser
donc ce qu'il vous fait généralement une
poupée en silicone de 50 kg l'enseigné
ses 8000 euros apparemment lui en fait
c'est un vrai phénomène si au japon il y
avait 3000 ventes de poupées par an my
heart on apprend que l'on partage sur un
mec qui avait une vie avec sa femme
et puis le week-end partez dans une
maison de campagne et retrouver sa
poussée et élus via les manger les mois
je me suis même posé la question est ce
que ça ne coûterait pas moins cher alain
cher maître que des poupées
oui virale b après on peut trouver sa
sordide et glauque mais il ya des gens
qui crèvent de la solitude et je pense
qu'il vaut mieux être avec une poupée
que faire du mal à quelqu'un lui
demander où les fromages
il est étonnant c'est que ce monsieur a
eu une histoire avec des familles là
même où je crois une famille et donc
c'est pas quelqu'un qui a été seule
toute sa vie c'est quelque chose de
positif dans tout ça c'est que c'est
tout en gueule avec elle tu as raison
tout le temps à bâle
il faudrait de mode comme ça qui nous a
aussi parlé de la vie qu'il menait que
sa compagne regarder un peu rna
s'installe dans votre vie comme votre
compagne officielle vous la présenter à
vos amis oui vous la présenter la botte
mer gelée est extraordinaire ma mère
elle est 100% open mind mes parents
d'une manière générale mon père est
décédé maintenant mais ils ont toujours
voulu que mon bonheur ils m'ont toujours
soutenu dans tout ce que j'ai fait elle
était 2016
un système permet à rna de se tenir
debout
vous allez me faire pleurer là j'ai
ouvert une porte et et reina était
derrière debout temps à ma hauteur
et elle regardait à moi et là avoue
pleurer j'ai craqué j'ai chialé comme
vous le dites c'est un des moments les
plus forts de notre histoire il ya un
ami qui me dit la coupe ehf est très
jeune il faut rappeler quand même à ceux
qui seraient tentés il faut pas voir
this trop pointu que ça peut exploser
autres bassiste et oui mais c'est pas le
plus gonflé c'est un mec s'est barré oui
peut-être qu'une poupée dont tu peux
vous fait des échalotes aux motards des
sauriens 6 ouf le mexique ils présentent
la joie je voyais après 0,5 ces [ __ ]
et comme nous a très vite et ce qu'on
peut dans la vérité s'arrêter n'importe
quel autre animateur on sera en train
d'insulter ici gilbert des doigts les
services on dit rien c'est ardisson qui
vaut sans problème machine à buzz
il fait n'importe quoi et là pardon
c'est vraiment ridicule c'est une
machine
si vite voilà ce que c'est de rouler
fait parler la poupée dans son émission
il est traité de manière sérieuse
ouais ça c'est un truc non je crois
qu'elle dit non tout le temps sinon
merci j'avais entièrement d'accord avec
mathieu je me senti un grand malaise en
voyant la série je ne l'aurais pas
diffusé c'est pas nouveau mais bon c'est
comme ça parce que ça va bien pour ce
pack wiimote eut dit vous êtes un garçon
complètement folle et on ya déjà
beaucoup de sous